BELOVED.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
ALL RIGHT, DOCTOR, I’M GOING TO
START WITH YOU.
WHEN YOU HEAR DEBORAH BIRX,
DR. BIRX, SAY THAT IT IS
DEVASTATINGLY WORRISOME TO SEE
PEOPLE OUTSIDE BREAKING THE
GUIDELINES THAT WE ALL HAVE
AGREED UPON HAVE KEPT US SAFE
AND CONTINUE TO, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> Dr. Siegel: HARRIS, I THINK
-- THERE’S A COUPLE OF THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL, IT DEPENDS ON THE
STATE.
SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT MICHIGAN,
WHERE THERE’S BEEN 45,000 CASES,
AND A RECENT SURGE.
NOT CLEAR THAT THEY ARE
FLATTENING THE CURVE.
YOU KNOW, FLORIDA IS ABOUT
35,000 CASES, BUT IN FLORIDA THE
QUESTION ISN’T, IN MY MIND, IN
MY OPINION, WHETHER THE BEACHES
SHOULD BE OPEN, BUT HOW LONG YOU
KEEP THEM OPEN WHEN THERE ARE NO
PUBLIC BATHROOMS.
IS IT POSSIBLE TO KEEP SOCIAL
DISTANCING ON THE BEACHES?
>> Harris: EW.
>> Dr. Siegel: I THINK IT
MIGHT BE.
YOU SEE PEOPLE WALKING ALONG THE
SIDEWALKS ANYWAY.
THE REAL QUESTION IS, REGION BY
REGION, HOW MANY CASES HAVE YOU
FLATTEN THE CURVE AND CAN YOU
GET PEOPLE OUTSIDE AND AWAY?
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
BOY, A COUPLE OF HOURS ON THE
BEACH, IF YOU CAN OBEY THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING, IS GREAT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH IN A STATE LIKE
FLORIDA.
>> Harris: YOU TALK ABOUT
BATHROOM FACILITIES,
HAND WASHING IS SUCH A HUGE PART
OF ALL THIS.
NO MATTER HOW MUCH HAND
SANITIZER YOU HAVE AT THE BEACH,
IT MIXES WITH SAND.
I’VE GOT TO IMAGINE YOU’VE GOT
KIND OF A MESS ON YOUR HANDS.
YOU NEED TO GO AND WASH THEM
OFF.
THE LENGTH OF TIME IS SOMETHING
THAT PROBABLY, LEGALLY, COULD BE
TALKED ABOUT, TOO.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO ADD THAT INTO
YOUR GUIDELINES.
EMILY, I’M GOING TO ASK YOU,
WITH YOUR LEGAL BACKGROUND.
ARE ANY OF THESE LEADERS ON
SHAKY GROUND, IF THE GUIDELINES
REALLY ARE TOO WIDE?
NOTWITHSTANDING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS SAID THEY
NEED TO TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT
THEM AND THAT THEY MAY BE
OVERSTEPPING.
YOU HEAR DR. SIEGEL TALKING
ABOUT BACK DOMINIC BATHROOM
FACILITIES AT THE BEACH.
>> Emily: WRIGHT, THE ISSUE
BECOMES WHEN CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS AND LIBERTIES ARE BEING
INFRINGED.
THAT IS REALLY WHEN THERE IS A
VERY HIGH BAR FOR THESE
GOVERNORS AND THE STATE LEADERS
TO CROSS, IF THEY’RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO PASS JUDICIAL MUSTER.
WE’VE TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE,
THE TEST IS WHETHER IT’S THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE MEANS OF
ACCOMPLISHING A LEGITIMATE GOAL.
SO THE PLAINTIFF CAN ARGUE,
"LOOK, HERE’S A WAY TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS LEGITIMATE
PUBLIC HEALTH GOAL WITHOUT
TRAMPLING ON MY CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT," THEN THAT IS WHEN THEY
ARE ON SHAKY GROUND.
I HAVE TO SAY, DR. SIEGEL
TOUCHED ON THAT REGIONAL NATURE.
I’M SITTING HERE IN WASHINGTON,
I’M FROM CALIFORNIA.
MY GOVERNOR JUST EXTENDED THE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER THROUGH THE
END OF THIS MONTH, BUT HE
ANNOUNCED A 4-PHASE PLAN, EACH
PHASE LASTING ABOUT THREE WEEKS.
HE HAS REFUSED TO GIVE SPECIFIC
DATA THAT HAS LED HIM TO THIS
CONCLUSION, BECAUSE HE SAYS,
"I’M WAITING FOR TO BE
FAVORABLE."
THE DIFFERENCES THAT HERE HE HAS
ALLOWED ANY COUNTY THAT DOES
MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA TO
BASICALLY APPLY TO BE EXEMPT.
AND HE SAYS THERE ARE TEN
COUNTIES HERE THAT ESSENTIALLY
COULD GET BACK TO WORK SOONER.
IN CALIFORNIA, THAT’S 58
COUNTIES, 15 OF WHICH HAVE SEEN
ZERO DEATHS.
AND YET, GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM